he went on The View because they were
having trouble explaining why despite
Biden's vivaciousness and energy and all
of those things why is it that people
don't seem to support the guy so chuck
had to run some cover Senator President
Biden State of the Union doubled as a
soft launch soft launch for 2024 and
President Biden has made historic
accomplishments which you were speaking
to in job growth Health Care
infrastructure but in ABC News poll uh I
know earmuffs a whoopee uh says that the
voters are even less enthused about
Biden running again than Trump now can
you explain the disconnect between what
we are seeing in the successes and what
the polling is showing I think first you
can't always believe polio thank you
hey there was a poll in 1983 that said
Ronald Reagan would get clobbered and of
course he won a huge Victory but second
I think part of it is that we now have
to make sure the American people they've
read what we have done yeah but they
haven't seen it yeah
Chuck Schumer doesn't have a neck
he's just a head on a body you might
want to look into a neck extension or
you know those women that put the Rings
so they get that long neck we gotta get
one of those for Chuck
um okay so Define you know my feelings
about the polls you don't always have to
believe in the polls but what I thought
was interesting about that clip is you
see uh they're not getting the results
right they see that people aren't into
the Biden thing okay he stood there he
didn't collapse his brain didn't explode
so be it but they're not seeing enough
people just falling for it on top of the
fact that him running as an 84 year old
or whatever it'd be would be the most
giant ridiculous farce of all time there
already is a massive conspiracy running
in the white house which is that they
drug him for these things there is no
doubt about it it will come out one day
News Guard you can watch this show right
now and said Dave Rubin says that
they're drugging Joe Biden and yes they
are drugging Joe Biden I don't need the
receipts it is obvious okay there's
something wrong with him if he was your
grandfather and constantly babbling and
confused and shaking hands with ghosts
and telling stories that made no sense
you would say grandma or you'd say mom
can we get Grandpa to the doctor
[Music]